hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts application of long read
packed bio sequencing for high
resolution metagenomics presented by dr.
jonas carla chief scientific officer
Pacific Biosciences I am Kaylee baka
bobrucz and I will be your moderator for
today's event we're delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by labrys bobberts is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen type your questions into the
drop down box and click send will answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please look on the
helpdesk button located on the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen or use the ask a question
box to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Jonas koyla I will now turn the
presentation over to him thank you very
much hello everyone and buying me to
once again present at the lab for
conference I think this might at least
my third time so it's a pleasure to be
back and yeah today the topic will be
metagenomics and how long we Peck by
sequencing can be applied to a high
resolution picture of those communities
this is the topics for today's talk I'll
give a very brief overview of the
company and also the technology and
where we are on an update with regard to
the performance and then the most time
I'll spend on talking about the
metagenomics applications and
opportunities that are associated with
PacBio sequencing so for those of you
who don't know PacBio Pacific
Biosciences came out of Cornell
University on permanent mm it's now
headquartered in California in the Bay
Area and we have one product and
associated consumables that's the sequel
system commercializing this thing real
time platform in four hundred forty
employees the other thing I want to
mention is that we have a very
experienced management team you see up
there on the left my conquer pillar who
was by many considerate the father of
commercial DNA sequencing here an API
for many years he's our CEO and then I
want to mention Kathy Ordonez is our
chief commercial officer
she ran Roche and Raindance a very
experienced with regard to
commercializing complex biotechnological
systems now by way of motivation as an
introduction of course many of you
realize already that there many
challenges associated with sequencing
metagenomic community communities and
this has been commented on in many
papers and perspectives here's just two
examples and of course the challenge
there is that these are very
heterogeneous populations they're uneven
and with regard to their abundance ease
so some of the species and strains are
and high abundances some are very rare
and they're also not static they're
highly dynamic as the environment
changes the communities change and so
forth and so it's been recognized and
commented on that the short read
sequencers are really not very well
suited to characterize these kinds of
communities so just one quote on the
bottom right there from this paper on
the left that even if you have the
easiest communities these are MOC
communities where you know what's going
in and there are even abundance because
these are artificial communities the
best assemblers only reconstruct about
two thirds of what's actually there so
you're missing one third completely and
the two thirds that are there are in
context that are you know just lightly
larger than 150 base pairs so you have
an incomplete view and a fragmented view
using short rate of sequencing and so
with regard to sequencing performance as
it pertains to characterizing these
metagenomic communities
there of course three criteria that you
want to look at this is generally so so
whenever you want to look at a
sequencing technology those are the
three areas you want to evaluate with
regard to performance I'll talk about
cost and workflow at the end of the
presentation but in terms of just in
terms of quality of the sequence these
are the three topics that you want to
look at the first one is how long are
the reads second one is how accurate is
the result that you're getting and the
third one is is there any bias with
regard to watch your can sequence
meaning can you sequence all the DNA and
that's a part of your sample so we
regard to that performance and peg BIOS
current performance we now have average
read lengths that are greater than
15,000 bases for genomic DNA and about
twice that about 30,000 bases on average
for amplicons and I'll give examples in
both of those areas that's about two
orders of magnitude longer than what you
can do with Illumina sequencing and I've
listed on the right to representative
performance examples and you can see
that there is read length distribution
so on the x-axis you've seen the read
length and on the y-axis is the
histogram the bins of the number of
reads in that with that read length and
you can see there's a long tail that's
because in single molecule real time
sequencing some polymerase has go faster
than others and and will create longer
reads and of course there is twice as
many bases in a 40 KB read compared to a
20 KB reads so most of the data will be
in that long tail in the distribution so
that's expressed by the parameter that's
called read and 50 that's the read
length beyond which half of the data are
contained therein
so for genomic DNA the read and 50 is
over 30 KB and for amplicons to read and
50 you notice that the scale is
different on the bottom compared to the
top is over 70 Kb so half the data with
amplicons are now contained in reads and
are greater than 70 thousand bases or
higher
we forgot to consensus accuracy that's
the final result that you're getting
it's been
demonstrated and noted in many papers
that PacBio has very high consensus
accuracy even though on the single read
level the errors is relatively higher
compared to alumina the errors are
random so they wash out as you built
coverage and so at about 25 fold
coverage you get to QE 40 or 99.99%
accuracy and about 50 fold coverage you
get to 99.999% or less than one error in
a hundred thousand fifty and then with
regard to bias with regard to let's say
GC content or sequence complexity where
you have dinucleotide or trinucleotide
repeats and very low complexity sequence
it's also been described and
demonstrated that PacBio has the least
bias of any technology and on the right
I'm showing just one example with regard
to the GC content of the DNA so on the
on the left of the graph you have highly
eighty rich DNA and on the right of the
graph you have GC rich DNA and on the
y-axis is the sequencing coverage and
you can see that's very even much more
even than you have with other
technologies and that means that
regardless of what the sequence is you
get the same kind of representation and
saint quality associated with the pec
bio data so this has been these what we
this has been commented on by the
community about the advantages of smart
sequencing the middle paper was a
specific evaluation of different
technologies in this case alumina and
torrent Complete Genomics MPEG bio
showing that PET bottle is the least
bias in sequence data and on the bottom
is a relatively new paper review paper
that this particular paper is for
medical diagnostics but it is generally
true that the previous myth that smart
sequencing was too error-prone to be
useful is now being expunged and
replaced by evidence that it actually
offers advantages over short read
sequencers so fundamentally what we were
trying to do here is to build a system
into sequencing technology that has
excellent performance in all three of
these criteria simultaneously
and whereas the other technologies short
reads obviously they don't have and
actually quite considerable bias and
with other long.we technologies like 10x
genomics Oxford nanopore they do create
long or linked reads but have
deficiencies in the accuracy and again
in the bias and so you're really not
leveraging the full potential that you
could get from a sequencing performance
that has very good performance in all
three areas simultaneously and so the
price we have to pay initially was the
throughput and over the lifetime of the
commercialization of this technology
over the past six years we have built on
that foundation of high quality and
increase the throughput by well over
thousand fold now first on the papaya RS
to the instrument on the left and now
the smaller system of the sequel system
which currently gives about up to 10
Giga bases per smart cell with genomic
DNA and up to 20 Giga bases for smart
cell with amplicons and then in the
system there's a robotics unit that
allows you to run up to 16 smart cells
in with the press of a button and in a
walkaway operation so if you multiply
those cores you get to some fairly
serious throughput for a machine run so
that's the walkaway operation of the
machine processing one smart self there
another of several hundred or up to 200
Giga bases 4.2 tera bases so this has
then has led to quite a number of
high-profile publications there by now
well over 3,300 publications to date on
average there's about five new papers
that are published highlighting the
utility of smart sequencing every day
and so you can see that and we believe
that it's because of that underlying
performance we believe we've that's the
reason for this fairly rapid increase in
the number of publications so I would
like to focus on today so you know these
papers are described where in all areas
that are relevant to human health plants
and animals
trician human genomics of course and
then infectious disease and so forth but
today I would like to focus just on
metagenomics and so in the area of
discussing meta genomic applications and
opportunities there are three topics
that I'd like to cover the first one is
targeted sequencing of the 16s gene for
classification the second one is shotgun
metagenomics and then at the end I want
to give highlighting some opportunities
in transcriptomes and epigenomes
in these metagenomic communities so in
order to to highlight the ability the
unique ability of Peck bio to get highly
accurate results from these complex
communities I want to introduce another
way of getting the sequencing consensus
with PacBio sequencing so on the left
you see what I would call standard
sequencing where you have a number of
molecules there are sequenced separately
and then you build either through
resequencing and mapping to a reference
sequence or through overlap de novo
assembly you build coverage and then you
have a final consensus sequence that is
your final result with Peck
biotechnology it's uniquely possible to
get highly accurate sequencing results
on an individual DNA molecule level and
we call this circular consensus
sequencing or CCS this feature is not
available of any other technology be it
short read or long read technology and
the way it works is that we like these
hairpin adapters to a linear
double-stranded DNA molecule so that it
becomes topologically circular even
though structurally it's still linear
and then the polymerase will start
reading the DNA and it will start going
around in a circle opening up this
hairpin structure we call the smart Bell
and continues to sequence in a rolling
circle mode so what that means is that
the polymerase will sequence this
individual strand of DNA multiple times
the forward strand and the reverse
strand and so it's possible to get
multiple reads on the same DNA molecule
then you can build consensus from that
and get a very highly read from that in
a molecule in this particular case for
example identifying that there was an
additional green mutation that on the
left would have been washed out in the
multi molecule consensus so we would
then use the left standard sequencing
for things like the novo assembly and
I'll get to that and the later part of
the talk and then on the right is
specifically useful for characterizing
these complex men of genomic mixtures
where essentially every day in among DNA
molecule is unique and is different and
you need to call them on the individual
DNA molecule level regardless of which
mode of sequencing you use you get the
same kind of high consensus accuracy and
how it evolves with coverage that I
described earlier so with regard 16s
sequencing which is now enabled through
the long read Lang Smith Peck bio there
was a paper really highlighting that
this is a new gold standard in microbial
community profiling we forgot to through
their phylogeny this was a paper a
little while ago from key opinion
leaders and cue
leading researchers in this particular
area and they applied smart sequencing
for microbial community profile
generating full-length 16s RNA gene
sequences with high throughput and as a
new term they call these Philo tags and
so in the paper they demonstrate that
this new utility fills important gaps in
the tree of life improved classification
and has important implications for
inferring than the metabolic potential
and biogeochemical roles of these
microorganisms in natural and human
engineer ecosystems so they highlight
that having a full-length say sequence
of this particular gene is much more
powerful and through all taxonomic
levels but you see in particular at the
genus and species level you get much
higher classification percentages
compared to on the right is the v4
segment that's typically utilized with
these eye tags with Illumina sequencing
and on the bottom is an example
demonstrating how you can get
fool by just looking at a portion of a
gene so with the before here you have
two Salmonella subspecies that are
identical in sequence in that before
element however when you do the
full-length PacBio 16s sequencing you
see that they're quite different in
other variable regions and can be
distinguished and then the authors went
into a natural environment this is a
lake in Canada and without going into
much detail all the black bars that you
see we're classified according to the
Peck bio full-length information but
we're ambiguous according to the
Illumina technology and so we see
there's a lot of information that was
missed with the shortly technologies
that is now elucidated with Peck bio
sequencing another example that's been
published is about fecal microbiome
transplantation very important and very
successful for treating Clostridium
difficile infections and this paper by
European researchers looked at the fecal
transplant evolution in the recipient
and found that it can take many months
six to seven months before there's a
stable adapted microbiome in the gut of
the recipient matching the donor so it
can take quite some time and getting
very detailed and comprehensive
information about these families that
are being transplanted so you can see
here that before the FMT on the left
there was a much lower diversity of and
this is at the stray some case and the
strain level a much lower diversity and
then after the fecal microbiota
transplant which is what you want are
you much more diverse much richer
microbiome I do want to point out that
this paper is quite interesting this is
a side note also looking at the bacteria
phages in the gut microbiome which is
typically not done but of course it's
now being recognized that the phages are
also very important for human health and
well-being there are other papers that I
won't have time to talk about today
demonstrating the utility on full-length
16s sequencing there's a microbiome
paper
and these are more methods paper another
one for cream difficile infections and
then this is in the ecology and
environmental sciences looking at soil
bacterial communities looking at
communities with implications on
atmospheric nitrogen deposition etc so
this has been demonstrated that you can
get really high quality information from
full-length 16s sequencing and there's
actually a talk in about one hour so I
encourage you to stay on a mark driscoll
from shoreline bio will talk about
applying this in various ways with
regard to microbiome profiling so I
encourage you to check out his talk as
part of roots event as well where forgot
to shotgun metagenomics of course
there's now a movement towards not just
looking at what is there but
understanding that more comprehensively
by looking at the entire genome and
again this unique CCS capability that I
described earlier allows you to get much
higher resolution for shotgun
metagenomics with Peck bio on what we
can do here is we can take let's say two
or three kilobase fragments and then
again in this circular consensus
sequencing mode go around that molecule
sequencing at multiple times and get
very high read accuracy greater than
let's say ninety-nine point seven
percent and that allows you to get a
much more contiguous view of sections of
those genomes you can often get multiple
complete genes per sequence read and
that requires no assembly and so in
general Peck bio is very powerful for
high resolution shotgun minute rooms at
the genus species and strain level and
I'd like to give some examples that
highlight this capability so this was a
paper by European researchers
demonstrating that with this circular
consensus sequence data you can improve
my Tomita genome assemblies and
taxonomic pinning the CCS provided the
dramatic improvement in the Assembly of
the universal marker gene in comparison
to the Illumina IC 2000 data and as
ability enabled the enhancements in
genome reconstructions of these
uncultured micro organisms that inhabit
complex communities so just as one
example from this paper comparing
directly picked bio and Illumina in the
same sample this was a bioreactor sample
there was there were two clostridia
species one clostridia and one firma qts
that accounted for about forty percent
of the entire biomass and the entire
community and those were basically
missed with the Illumina technology
largely because of extreme sequence
context and those are indicated in blue
and turquoise on the left and you can
see there's very little blue and
turquoise on the right so the majority
that almost half of the biomass was
missed with the Illumina so it's not
just a rare species that you missed with
Illumina sometimes it can be even the
dominant species and so as I mentioned
there can be multiple complete genes per
sequence per sequence read that comes
off the instrument this is an example
that was presented last year at AG BT
meeting of a cow rumen microbiome and
you can see that for these calves or
adult cows on average in this table on
the rightmost column you get two to
three genes per read and that's very
powerful because um if you find a gene
of interest let's say an antibiotic
resistance gene you have at least one or
maybe two genes on the same molecule
that then tell you which organism this
particular gene is a portion of and so
in this work it was also demonstrated
that there are benefits over the
Illumina technology in orange you see
the Illumina coverage in blue you see
PacBio and on the leftmost
side of this graph those are the rare
species that may only have you know one
fold coverage or so so you see those
molecules very rarely but because of the
high accuracy with Peck bile you get
very detailed and much more contiguous
information that allows you to classify
it and so you have a much better view of
the the rare species which
sometimes counterintuitive many people
think that because you don't have the
read depth with PacBio compared to
alumina you're not as sensitive to the
rare species but that's only partly the
truth because with the longer contiguity
of 3kb if you have one read that is
immediately useful and classifiable
whereas if you have one 150 based
alumina read you may not be able to make
inferences from that and so then you can
compare this with the Illumina data
these are assemblies from the CCS reads
they generate long context some in
excess of a hundred thousand bases are
much longer than what you see with
Illumina so in this picture on the the
black bar is the Peck bio context of
just over 100 KB and on the bottom in
gray you see the Illumina context which
are much shorter and their component so
it shows that the assembly that we made
with Peck bio was correct and then you
can add some data from an unshared
library to have bigger molecules and
that and then do a de novo assembly and
in some cases you get complete microbial
genomes which is quite unprecedented for
difficult microbial communities such as
the cow rumen that's been a an
environment that's been very tough to
study and so we have one complete genome
another nearly complete four megabytes
genome many contexts that were in excess
of 100 KB and the researchers shown here
from Israel
who we collaborated with we're very
excited about these unprecedented
quality results now I want to speaking
about complete genomes well sometimes
it's not regarded as the sort of
standard microbiome community work in
many cases it's now possible with PacBio
to get complete genomes from these micro
communities with a de novo assembly and
that allows unprecedented insight into
the complete blueprint of some of these
organisms I want to give just a couple
examples this was a
with Julie Segre and Julie oh oh and
when she was still at the NIH nurse
Jackson Laboratories resolving the
complexity of human skin made
metagenomes using smart sequencing we
were able to obtain a high-quality
closed genome of a previously
uncharacterized rhino bacterium and it's
bacteriophage from a skin metagenomic
sample in earlier paper and science
looked at the human gut and determined
the complete genomes of some of these
Bacteroides genomes and the paper itself
was about trying to correlate the
fitness and diet responsiveness in the
human gut with regard to the microbiomes
there are many other examples that I
won't go into looking at the complete
genomes from symbionts that are in a
fungus growing ants looking and the
second papers reminds looking at chanela
and these are in the microbiome so
freshwater fish and a third paper and
mole methods paper and then also for the
purposes of probiotics complete genomes
of probiotic bacteria that were isolated
from the gut of either infants or
healthy adults looking at a
contamination and food safety both in
human and also an animal and veterinary
safety a couple other examples of I
thought really clever uses of the
technology for shotgun metagenomics that
are bit different this is a finished
group evaluating the mobility potential
of antibiotic resistance genes in
environmental resistance without
metagenomics is the title and so it's
it's quite clever what the researchers
have done here focusing on the
antibiotic resistance genes or Arg as
you see in this figure and what you want
to know is whether those antibiotic
resistance genes are within mobile
genetic elements meaning they are still
capable of being transferred from one
bacterium to another or whether they are
essentially dormant and will not be
mobile and so the researchers came up
with a very nice inverse PCR based
targeted
approach just getting at those elements
sequencing them and then because of the
long read lengths of Peck bio you get
the flanking sequences of those
antibiotic resistance genes that allow
you to determine whether or not they're
within mobile genetic elements or not so
this is going at a specific question
that's at the heart of many studies
looking at the resistance the antibiotic
resistance and being very efficient in
pulling out the information that you
want the last example also in the area
of antibiotic resistance genes was
looking at a cow manure and playing
smart sequencing to significantly extend
the roster of functional antibiotic
resistance genes found in animal gut
bacteria the problem here is that
because we've treated livestock with
antibiotics for so many decades that
then goes into the soil and selects for
antibiotic resistant bacteria and so
this study used Fosnight sequencing
actually to get a much better
understanding and have lots of
discoveries of new antibiotic resistance
genes on the left on this bar chart only
the leftmost bar is something that has
any match in the GenBank database but
blast all the other bars in the middle
are new discoveries and have essentially
no similarity with GenBank and then on
the right in this picture you see that
again because of the long read links you
get an immediate understanding not just
of the antibiotic resistance gene but
also how they are organized within their
hosts within those bacteria and what
particular genes are right next with
cetera so there are many other
publications that I can go into here's a
list and I invite you to look at our
website under PEC be comm publications
we have a complete list and searchable
database of all the publications so then
lastly on the topic of transcriptomes
and epigenomes we're excited about
collaboration with New England Biolabs
looking at full-length microbial RNA
seek so as you know the read links have
been utilized in I so seek in eukaryotes
for quite a few years and we have
adapted
protocol with the smart capital sikri
agents from any be to make that possible
also now in bacteria and in metagenomic
communities and of course that's
exciting because you don't only want to
know what's there but in many cases you
want actively growing what is being
expressed and how it's being regulated
and so this paper highlights the
methodology and first applications that
you now get a much more complete and
comprehensive view of bacterial
transcriptomes you can see here the
operands being expressed and each line
each of those gray lines represents a
full-length transcript and you can see
already visually very clearly that it's
not nearly as simple as having just
transcripts that span the operon in many
cases one or two genes either in the
beginning or the end are missing so
there's a lot of regulation that is much
more difficult to get at with shorter e
technologies and is immediately apparent
with the long repack bio sequencing and
then finally with regard to the DNA
modification detection this is to
characterize the chemical modifications
that are put on DNA by the bacterial
methylation marks and six methyl adenine
four methyl cytosine 5 methylcytosine we
described I think about six or seven
years ago that the progression of the
polymerase is delayed by the presence of
a methyl group in the template strand so
the polymerase runs along the DNA and
then if it encounters a methylated base
that methylated base acts as a little
speed bump and the polymerase will take
a little bit longer time to get past
that and we measure that in real-time
and thereby can infer whether or not
they wear methylation marks on the DNA
this has been described it published
upon in many papers well over 150 papers
again I've listed them here but they're
all available in our publication
database which is the link is on the
bottom and so the community has
recognized that with PacBio sequencing
we have now entered a new era of
bacterial epi
and this was an older review article and
top a newer one from a few months ago
looking at so-called phase variance
those are variation in bacteria with
regard to the pathogenicity often that
are mediated by methylation and this is
an excellent review article summarizing
the work that has been done in this
particular area there all this
information is being recorded and
curated by the rebase database that's
curated by New England Biolabs and you
can see there well over 5500 records by
now the PEC bio data and if you have
bacterial pack bio data please submit
them to the rebase database so that the
entire community can benefit from that
information even if you don't use it for
your own research it's very important
biological information that is useful
for others with regard to methylation in
metagenomics there are a number of
examples highlighting that this is an
important topic this is a paper from
Eric Triplett in Florida looking at the
methylation of gut microbiomes
and asking the question whether in
conjunction with a disease in this
particular case type 1 diabetes and the
development of autoimmunity against this
disease whether there are differences
and the paper describes the profound
differences in the dominant bacterium
that was a Bacteroides in the extent of
damn methylation between two children
that had a high genetic risk for type 1
diabetes and a year prior to the
development of type 1 diabetes in one of
these children but not in the other so
this is certainly no proof but it's an
indication that we should look at the
methylation status of the gut microbiome
in addition to just the sequences this
is an area from the agriculture and
example from the agricultural space you
know 12 years ago there was a paper
showing that there are dramatic
differences in the methylation changes
during symbiosis of these bacteria that
form associations with the root nodules
of nitrogen fixing bacteria that form in
symbiosis with
and of course back then there was no
commercial smart sequencing and so this
was a paper just looking at the
transition from the free living state to
the nodule of those bacteria in the soil
and finding that there are dramatic
methylation changes so I'd always hope
that someone would apply smart
sequencing and this was then done 10
years later in 2016
again by Eric Triplett looking in detail
about the methylation and gene
expression data in the development of
one of those bacteria during symbiosis
and their dramatic changes 35% of all
the genes are affected there are over
ten percent of these methylation changes
are in this what he called symbiosis
Islands you can see that on the bottom
that is denoted by the two dashed lines
there's a region in the genome that
changes dramatically both with regard to
methylation and expression and the
methylation is there's one methylation
motif that's specific to symbiosis and
768 genes have methylation and
significant expression changes so this
isn't a phenomenon that you absolutely
have to measure and understand if you
want to understand symbiosis and the
interaction of bacteria with plants in
this particular case and then finally
one quite recent example from Gong Fong
at Mount Sinai School of Medicine in New
York City looking at harnessing and
leveraging the methylation information
to improve binning for these metagenomic
communities and this Nature
Biotechnology paper he looked at the
endogenous epigenetic barcodes the
methylation signals that he can then use
as barcodes from the PacBio data to
resolve either the individual reads or
the assembled contacts into species and
strain level pins it allowed him to link
the plasmids and other mobile genetic
elements to their host species because
they carry the same methylation marks
they're in the same bacterial cell so
the methyl transferases will methylate
both the chromosome and the plasmids and
mobile genetic elements and so it very
nicely complements existing methods to
enable more accurate sequence pinning
and so if you're interested in that I
encourage you to look at bounce paper so
with that I'll close and just summarize
and I mentioned that you know I talked
about sequencing performance but of
course cost and the workflow is also
very important for making it into
efficient assays and making that routine
and so with regard to the workflow and
the cost we have introduced an
accelerated library prep or Express
library prep as we call it previously
the library prep took about a day but
with this new protocol that we rolled
out a few months ago it's significantly
faster it only takes three hours and
requires less starting material about
two and a half times less it's more
efficient because you handle the DNA
differently it's just an ad only
workflow and because you're handling the
DNA less there's also less damage to the
DNA and so you have longer read links
and improved sequencing performance and
of course it's amenable to automation
and this is currently available for the
long fragment protocols with regard to
the cost on one example is we forgot to
barcodes
just like any other technologies pick
bio sequencing has barcodes 384 of them
that have been optimized for smart
sequencing which then allows you to
multiplex hundreds of targets and
samples pull them together and sequence
them on a single smart cell the on the
bottom then the analysis software
automatically demultiplexers and puts
each barcode in a separate bin and then
does the analysis CCS or multi molecule
consensus and this can be scaled up
quite dramatically here's a paper
recently published entitled the sequel
to Sanger so it's equal to Sanger
sequencing Amla Khan sequencing that
scales by Paul Hebert and colleagues
from the biodiversity Institute in
Guelph Canada and they bar-coded and
pooled up to 10,000 amplicons in a
single smart cell and found that it was
both more accurate
and in in that the smart sequencing
provided more complete coverage
especially for amplicons before more
polymer tracks which are more
challenging for Sanger sequencing and
also more cost-effective 40-fold cheaper
compared to Sanger sequencing and still
an order of magnitude less expensive
compared to both alumina and iron
torrent so I realized that there's a
strong notion in the community that it's
about cost per base and so forth but we
like to think about it more in terms of
cost per project because sequencing
applications are now very different and
so different technologies have different
strengths and weaknesses and so a
technology that may be too expensive in
one area may actually be much cheaper in
another and so you really can't sort of
globally say cost per base because that
would not be appropriate over all the
different application spaces so as a
case in point Paul and colleagues ran a
project with Sanger sequencing here no
characterizing 200th s immense that cost
them 1.2 million dollars or about 120
million 120 thousand dollars with
chaudhary technologies and now it's you
know only thirty six thousand dollars so
about tenfold less than with aluminum
iron torrent and dramatically less with
with Sanger so with that I would like to
close and I hope that I've given you a
good overview of the unique capabilities
that picked bio sequencing can provide
in the area of metagenomics in the area
of targeted sequencing 16s or you can
adapt that to other genes of interest
that you're interested in we forgot to
shotgun metagenomics being able to get
much more contiguous information on two
or three kilobase fragments and getting
complete microbial genomes from these
representatives of these communities and
then emerging applications harnessing
the Peck biotechnology both for our new
research for transcriptomes
and very important the methylation
information for the epigenomes and so
with that I'll stop this is my
knowledge meant slide actually because
you notice that most of the things that
I talked about we're not done by us but
by the scientific community and so we
are extremely grateful for their efforts
and time applying the Peck biotechnology
in many cases moving it forward and we
are indebted to the researchers efforts
and it's been a great journey and
collaborations with all of them to apply
Peck biome to metagenomics but also to
other areas so with that I'd like to
thank you again for allowing me to
present at the meeting today and I'd be
happy to answer any questions thank you
thank you dr. Koh locks for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button well answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for let's get started
our first question asks what are your
plans for future improvements on sample
prep sequencing and data analysis yeah
thank you certainly so I focused on what
is possible today but we have obviously
plans to improve on all three aspects of
a sequencing project sample prep
sequencing and data analysis as you
mentioned and so just as a few examples
so in terms of sample preparation the
Express library kit that I mentioned
which is currently available for the
long insert cases we plan to make
available for all types of analysis so
amplicons for example 16s analysis and
so forth so that will be something that
is a future improvement on the sample
prep and working with the community to
automate that for people who have lots
and lots of samples that you don't want
to pipette by hand anymore with regard
to the sequencing we will continue on
this path that I mentioned on the
thousandfold improvement since the
inception we believe that there is still
quite a lot of
runway left on improving that even
further we're targeting about a two-fold
increase in the throughput for smart
cell for this year and then next year we
will introduce a new chip that will have
an eight fold higher multiplex so right
now there's a 1 million features on the
smart cell and next year we'll introduce
an 8 million feature smart cells so that
will directly translate to a
corresponding throughput increase in the
number of reads and of course I realized
that the number of reads is very
critical for many metagenomic
applications especially where you have
very complex communities but also making
it more cost efficient because in many
cases even now on sequel people
multiplex for example 16s experiments
because you need about let's say many
people need about 10 to 30,000 total
reads per sample out of a smart cell
right now you get about 400,000 reads
and so you can multiplex up to 10 or 12
samples in that case with barcodes once
the 8 million chip comes online that of
course you can either get a even more
multiplex factor or you can study more
deeply the very complex microbial
communities where you get where you need
more reads and uncover these rare
species and then with regard to data
analysis we're working very closely with
the community trying to incorporate the
knowledge and the databases and so we
have a smart link a smart analysis
package that's the PacBio
maintained software package but then
there is a and we will continue to add
features to that make it easier with
regard to non bioinformaticians to run
these types of analyses but then also
working with the community who develop
specific third-party tools that are
specific to certain types of metagenomic
analysis whether it's the 16s databases
or shotgun minute genomics and so forth
you know there's an interesting thing
that the database is because
it's been so dominated with the shorter
II technologies the databases are very
biased towards short read information so
you know the eye tags the v4 there is a
ton of itag data in the databases but by
comparison
very few full-length 16s sequences so I
think it's going to be important to
update those databases with the full
length information to really then
leverage the power of the studies to
come with regard to the classification
potential so in all three areas we have
a lot of improvements and futures
planned to make the technology more
powerful and then make it more cost
effective and more efficient to be
applied by the research community thank
you we have time for one more question
today and this one says what about DNA
quality for long read PacBio sequencing
in shotgun metagenomics getting long DNA
fragments out of isolates can sometimes
be challenging yeah thank you that is a
that is a very good point and you know
the community didn't have the need for
many years to get multi kilobase
fragments out of some of these
communities or some of these isolates to
characterize the meta genomic
communities and there is so we are
working on that but not in isolation
there the research community and many
companies have developed kits that can
be utilized to get longer fragments out
just one example I talked to
Shinichi Morishita he's a researcher at
the University of Tokyo and he found an
old protocol from over ten years ago
it's a lysosome a protocol that he
applied to stool samples microbiome
samples and found that it's very
efficient in getting eight to ten
kilobase fragments out of stool samples
which is really ideal for then following
up with pet bio sequencing and so he
presented this work last summer at a
conference in Tokyo and Japan and the
poster on this
much better characterization of these
gut microbiomes animals actually won won
the prize at that conference for best
poster so there are kids that are
available from a number of companies
that adapt now there are protocols to
long read long fragments
we'd like to also work with the
community and sort of a crowd based
effort because it's very useful to
curate and collect that information so
that people don't have to reinvent the
wheel so if you have success with
certain samples and of course the
challenge here is that there's so many
different environments right you have
marine environments ocean water lake
water you have soul environments you
have and the soil even can be very
different so there is no one type of
solution that's possible here because
the sample types are so different you
know you know and even in the human you
have the gut microbiome and then you
have skin microbiomes and so forth and
they may require very different DNA
isolation procedure so we really
encourage and welcome the community to
publish all of those even if not in
peer-reviewed publications as notes and
blogs or just send it to us and whether
we can post it there many of these
forums where this type of information
can be posted so it's really a community
effort but we see over the years where I
would say it was very challenging a few
years ago there are now a number of
established protocols and companies that
really have invested in this area and
are now offering products that can be
used there so I think you know your
question is very valid that can be
challenging but I would say it's
definitely getting less challenging as
more and more people practice it and
optimize these types of procedures to
get long DNA out of those samples thank
you I would like to once again thank dr.
Jonas core Locke for his presentation I
would also like to thank madrix for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
every
know that today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
August 2018 you will receive an email
from labyrinth letting you know when
this webcast will be available for
replay please share that an awesome with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon goodbye